great thanks for coming thanks for the
imitation so this is title talk
I mean goal the talk is to explain the
title so what is it hitting said what is
closure small to make circuits hopefully
you know key spaces so the main theorem
I want to kind of discuss and explain is
AP space construction so it's gonna be
algorithm that constructs some object
it's not just a decision problem but
it's a search problem it's gonna run in
P space and it's a piece based
construction of a set so it's gonna be
set curly H and it's going to be n
tuples of rational numbers and this the
set is gonna have two properties it's
going to be the hitting set which is
some pseudo random objects which are
able to find it'll hit the closure
there's also a notion I'll define of and
this is where the massive parameter
starts so it's gonna be size s degree D
and n variate polynomials and these
polynomials will be over the complex
numbers
okay so hitting set itself soon
irrational numbers but we're gonna
consider polynomials that have arbitrary
complex entries
so just alone this part the first part
is not so interesting the other
interesting part is the fact that this
hitting set is not too complicated and
it's going to be up signs polynomial in
s and indeed which are the three
parameters of interest okay and this is
also going to include say bit complexity
so it's they're also a small bit
complexity entries so the main goal is
again to explain what this there means
why it's interesting and perhaps why
it's difficult so first mark is Catan
then on Monday talked about his nether
normalization problem and he mentioned
that it's equivalent to constructing
hitting sets for VP bar and that's
basically what this theorem is doing in
P space so this is another one other we
put it is AP space algorithm to solve
this nether normalization probably for
explicit varieties okay I'm not gonna
use that language and the rest of this
talk okay so I do want to make a couple
remarks on this theorem first of all is
that this is going to be even though
this is an algebraic statement in the
sense that we have algebraic circuits
we're going to give an analytic proof
and as a result we need that the
characteristic of the field is going to
be zero as Catan mentioned in his work
in 2012 he gave an exponential space
algorithm using grosvenor basis theory
which is usually very complicated and
intense which is why it's exponential
space I don't think you mentioned this
but if you use some more ideas you can
actually get it in the exponential
hierarchy under the generalized view
hypothesis when you're working over the
complex numbers so this is slightly
better but still not what you would want
necessarily and the dream result would
be input on the time and this would
follow from sort of your very optimistic
dear analyzation hypotheses
and shortly after our workers posted and
we'll talk about next is that there's
actually an algebraic proof of this or
he'll talk about some part of that this
is by Kuo Saxena and Sinha Babu and
they're given algebraic proof and as a
consequence they're actually doing it
over arbitrary characteristic so they're
dropping this restriction that you have
something only in characteristic zero
okay so this is the theorem here there
are some remarks and I want actually do
want to tell you you know what exactly
some of these terms mean so yeah there
should be some general nonsense that
makes that true I can't do it online but
yes okay so just remind you what is an
algebraic circuit we've sort of seen
definitions but we can do it by example
right we can have x squared minus y
squared we can factor this as X plus y X
minus y in this corresponds to the
diagram or we have addition gates and
multiplication gates and we have leaves
at the bottom with variables x and y
with scalars on the edges this is not
the right way to do it so this is an
ultra brake circuit computing some sort
of polynomial so succinct way to
describe a potentially large
multivariate object and this is a
particular notion but then I want to say
what are the complexity classes of
interest once we have this notion of
complexity
that'll be roughly speaking VP but I'm
not gonna actually use that particular
term I'm just going to instead use these
slightly more cumbersome size s n ND
class okay so this is simply those
polynomials F which are complex valued
complex coefficients in n variables okay
they are going to be computed by
sighs s circuits and then you might see
where I'm going with this which is that
the degree of F is also at most D okay
so this is some complexity class that I
want to think about of course the main
goal maybe of this workshop but lower
bounds is finding explicit polynomials
which are outside assess like this for
various parameters snd and in pursuing
that goal
one of the main observations of GCT is
that the way we have approached this
problem very naturally fits into the
framework of algebraic geometry and all
our lower bound methods are continuous
so it's probably been mentioned and I'll
just remain it which is that most lower
bound methods are algebraic now maybe
that's not surprising in the sense that
we're doing algebraic Circuit lower
bounds right but I mean algebraic and
some precise sense which I'm not exactly
going to define but the consequence of
this is that these lower bounds just
don't lower bound against small circuits
but they lower bound against limits some
small circuits so these lower bounds
also apply to the limits small circuits
so I want to do an example to least make
it sort of clear what this means okay so
what's my example it's going to be very
bad example but so let's look at X it's
going to be an N by n matrix it's going
to be an N by n sort of symbolic matrix
it's not gonna not really in the lane of
polymers anymore but I would do one have
a notion of complexity and the most
natural one would be say rank okay so
how do I prove to you that a matrix is
low rank of course or high rank of
course no very easy the identity matrix
okay but we're doing kind of thinking in
the you know generic sense how do you
prove lower bounds
right we know that the rank of X is
deficient if it's less than n that
implies that the determinant of X is
zero right now of course this is
actually if and only if let's pretend we
don't actually know that
but what this is this gives us a way to
prove the rank is high right because if
we have then that the determinant of
some specific matrix X not it's nonzero
this implies that in fact the rank of X
is actually equal to n right so this is
yeah so this is a way to prove lower
bounds but the point is is that the
determinant itself is a polynomial and
polyols are continuous okay so it's now
suppose that we had some Y naught which
is the limit in the analytic sense of
some Y sub Epsilon it's ups onto some
parameter for every epsilon we have some
matrix okay and suppose that each y sub
epsilon is itself rank deficient what
does that mean that means then that the
determinant of Y sub naught is equal to
0 okay but the determinant again is a
polynomial it's continuous so that
implies that the determinant of Y naught
is also 0 so then using this condition
we can then conclude then in fact this X
naught is not the limit of rank less
than n matrices so here we have some
lower bound method that we did and we're
really only caring about rank and we
accidentally proved something a little
bit stronger which is that we also have
lower bounds against the limit no slower
and then pictorially or maybe
geometrically you can think about the
following okay so this dashed line is
going to be things which are of rank
less than n it strictly less than n ok
what this limiting process is doing is
it's taking a curve in this set ok and
this is some Y sub epsilon so epsilon
sort of parameterizing our curve and in
the end the limiting process is going to
give us Y naught and this entire set the
rank less than n lies in the set of
determinant equals 0 matrices and so
what this is really saying is that even
though we have a curve inside this
dashed line and in spend
possible although not actually in this
case that why not is outside this - line
why not cannot escape the locus of
determinant zero matrices okay so this
is what we're talking about the closure
in the sense that we're taking we're
looking at not just things that are
simple but also the limits of things
which are simple so we're taking a
particular closure in this case of like
say Euclidian closure in the including
topography okay so this is a very simple
example with matrix rank but how do we
then apply this to the land of plans
well we have this complexity class over
here small circuits right and we can
take the same sort of limits and get the
closure of small circuits okay so the
definition here is that we look at size
s and n D closure and that is simply
those polynomials F such that F is the
limit of F sub epsilon as epsilon goes
to 0 where each ups F sub epsilon is in
the appropriate unbarred notion
okay so we're taking small circuits and
then we're adding all of the closures
okay and I'm going to be bold and define
GCT apologies to katana as basically to
understand three different notions so
for every epsilon we have a poem you
know is that why should you even see
selectivity developments with epsilon so
yeah because I'm working in the analytic
notion I'm just going to say it's just
constants but if you work in the proper
algebraic stuff as Nitin will talk about
you can think of as polynomials or
rational functions in epsilon also but
I'm gonna avoid doing that okay so for
DCT
sort of three things we want to
understand so one is we want to
understand
okay I mean I'm tall I'm not this okay
so what do we want to understand
understand the following three classes
so one is small circuits okay we want
understand small circuits on the other
hand we want to understand explicit
polynomials things like the permanent if
you want to understand are these classes
in particular equal or unequal or so on
then in in the middle there's this size
bar okay
and the point is is that in Kaitlyn's
argument on Monday is sort of to
understand maybe this versus this we
kind of also need to understand what's
going on in the middle this is roughly
BNP but I do I also want to just make a
not quite proper but maybe illustrative
it'll be analogy with boolean complexity
which is here we have P here we have NP
and in the middle I'm gonna put P poly
and intersected with exponential time in
the sense that here we only have
decidable languages okay
it contains P and whenever we have say a
boolean circuit lower bound you know
we're not just proving the lower bounds
for P we're also proving Lauren rounds
for P Polly and there's some idea that
you know well if you want to really
understand the power of circuit lower
bounds you know in trying to prove
circular bounds for NP we might also
need to understand what's the difference
between these two classes and so today
what I want to do yes
is really not necessarily focused on the
economical problem of those explicit
problems versus here I wanna really
focus on this difference okay so today I
want to look at what are the differences
going on here
now one thing I do want to mention is
just for sanity checks is that you know
we don't have why we should expect these
to not be equal on just on a sandy
cheque which is that if you look at this
space because we have taken limits this
is actually a monomial in SN and D
dimensional algebraic variety and if you
look at all polynomials which maybe are
here this is going to be an N plus D
choose D dimensional variety so it's
clear that this in some sense is not too
big okay so it's reasonable to expect
these to be that this to be closer to
this then all polymers okay but one
understands focus on understanding
what's the difference between here and
here so I need to give you a particular
example to then really highlight because
of the determinants example which I'm
actually now erasing is not helpful
because rank is exactly characterized by
the determinant so let's look at
something where there really is a
difference between size and sidebar
let's consider an example which is going
to be warring rank or depth repowering
I'm gonna stick with the DEP you're
powering vacation so let's look at the
size of F being at most s in this sum of
power of some model and we're gonna say
it's at most s if F can be written as
the sum of Li of X to the D where I was
one from that one s okay where the
degree of Li is at most one okay so this
is going to be a linear polynomial that
we have taken to some power what power
well D is going to be the degree of L
and it's a non-trivial fact that every
polynomial can be computed in
exponential size in this model so it is
complete we have the fairly well
understood good understanding of lower
bounds for this model but there is
something non-trivial going on in
particularly at the border in the limits
so let's look at the size bar notion of
F is at most s again if F is equal to
the not actually not nobody is doesn
really matter but I said the green was 1
so again we can take the closure of this
set with respect to limits this gets a
potentially different class and now let
me give you an example of where limits
actually make a difference ok so let's
do a very simple example which is f is
equal to x squared times y two variables
you can express f as the following you
take so this is it cubic so this will be
homogeneous but whatever you take X plus
y and you cube it you divide play by 6
you subtract X minus y divided by 6
cubed and then you subtract off Y cubed
divided by 3 okay so you can go home and
check this last time I gave this talk I
made a mistake so please do check it but
the point is that this is an expression
and it implies that the size is at most
3 right because here's an actual
expression it's not obvious is that this
is in fact at least 3 and this follows
from like the eighth player you lemma I
don't remember the authors offhand but
this is these are people from algebraic
geometry so in fact you get that this is
the smallest expression for computing x
squared minus y as a sum of powers but
let's define F sub epsilon in the
following manner okay let's take now X
plus epsilon Y cubed divided by 6 so I'm
adding in my epsilon in some way
now we subtract X minus epsilon Y cubed
again divided by 6 now if you look at
the x cubed terms the x cubed terms
still cancel as you would expect but we
don't but we're really looking at now is
what's happening here and if you look at
the Y cubed term all right we're
dividing by Epsilon okay so the Y cubed
term has an epsilon cubed but we're
dividing by epsilon so this is going to
be equal to x squared my y plus epsilon
squared Y cubed divided by 3 so here
there was an epsilon and in each of
these terms but we divided by it okay
here you have an epsilon cubed we
divided by epsilon but it's still
epsilon squared so then if you take
epsilon to go to 0 alright this term
will survive this term will not survive
and it will go to 0 now we have x
squared Y so the size bar of this
expression is at most 2 so we do see a
non-trivial phenomenon going on at the
border here saying that there really is
a difference okay
yes but this talk is not actually about
lower bounds exactly it's about hitting
sets into your atomization so let me now
define that and tell you how this
example bears on that question so let's
define the following so have some
circuit class of polynomials x1 xn okay
so curly c is some circuit class and
we're willing to say that H is it if
it's you have some set of points H this
is a hitting set or see if for all F F
is the zero polynomial if and only if F
on your hitting set is also zero which
means that F on alpha is zero for all
alpha in your hitting zone
so we're asking is f as an algebraic
object zero that's equivalent to asking
is it zero and only these evaluations
okay so to test nonzero notes we just
need to say evaluate on all these points
and is any of these points yielding
something nonzero and the interesting
thing about this where GCT is
understanding what's the difference
between size and size bar well how
doesn't you know we saw a start on the
little bounds these questions are
different what about constructing
hitting sets and one of the observations
is is that if H hits a complexity class
C that does not imply that H hits
closure of C so what's an example this
is a contrived example but it's an
example nonetheless let's look at the
point zero one in this example the point
is is that F on 0 1 is just 0 squared
times 1 otherwise known as 0 but if you
look at F of epsilon on 0 1 right at the
tops along this is going to be 0 this is
going to be 1 cubed times you know
epsilon square divided by 3 right this
is epsilon square divided by 3 and this
is nonzero right so if you look at the
you know C curly see curly C is just
this collection of polynomials that's a
collection of polynomials and this
single point is a hitting set for this
entire collection right but it does not
hit F which is in the closure okay so
it's sort of saying that if we want to
get hitting sets for the closure we need
to maybe think a little bit more that's
what this talk did we think we thought
okay so let's now pull back to the
general setting of some all circuits as
opposed to just this particular example
of warring rank and that's what do we
know
so the conjecture is is that there is a
polynomial in s and nd time explicit
hitting set or you know circuits of the
appropriate size all right so not not
with the clothes are just regular
circuits okay so this is basically
saying that you know P I T is innocent P
under the black box setting okay and
what we know things normally showed is
that well if we relax this we can still
get something okay so in particular you
can get the same result but instead of P
you get P space and so you can get
something in pH so not just the P space
but in pH if you assume the general
hypothesis leasing characteristic 0 and
so I want to explain actually how this
proof goes because there's a lesser
ative and for how it'll work in the
closure before I say that I want to make
one remark each C part does not it does
not imply
so this is C F sub epsilon is C and it
hits C but it does not hit C bar because
this is this is the C bar okay so I want
to make one point which is that in this
example in the setting we know that
random sets are hitting sets everyone
knows that VPP is contained in P space
you know
QED because therefore obviously if this
is B P P then the PV space which should
be trivial
okay that's naive argument why is that
not helpful this does not imply that
there's a bppe explicit algorithm the
same reason that random strings are
coming off random but that does not mean
that we could actually find one right so
here it's like random objects are in
fact hitting sets but we want to like
put our hands on one without any
randomness okay so we're asking
basically we're allowing ourselves
arbitrary resources but no no actual
randoms okay so this is you know P space
is a deterministic algorithm that can
actually certify the output something
with probability one that's certifiable
you're hitting set not just with some
probability okay so what's the proof
sketch of this this P space table okay
so what does it mean to say that H is
not a hitting set what it means is that
you're violating this condition right
there's a particular a nonzero
polynomial that is always zero on your
hitting center alright so I can phrase
that a little bit differently is saying
that there is this exists an F in the
size class that's that first of all it's
nonzero and second of all it's always
here on your head except I'm going to
phrase that a little bit differently and
saying there's also a point alpha not in
say C to the N such that F of alpha
naught is nonzero
okay so this is a proxy for saying that
F itself is nonzero but we have that F
of alpha zero for all alpha in H for all
points on our heading sighted zero this
is another way of phrasing it and I want
to say that this condition is
intuitively something that we can check
in NP the sense that I want to prove
yeah yeah yeah four or whatever
complexity cost you're working in if I
want to prove to you something it's not
a hanging set I can give you the circuit
right now I can give you the point and
then you just verify that first of all
it sounds you're on this point and it's
also zero on all the points in your
heading set now what's what's wrong with
this is that we're working over the
complex numbers right and this is really
the setting of that or normalization
also algebraic you know the the general
closure setting usual you have to work
over an algebraically closed field
there's no way for me to necessarily
succinctly give you in bits for example
a circuit of this complexity class right
here you have PI even if e e to the PI e
to the PI to the PI you know you could
be ideal okay so we have to use
something a little bit more
sophisticated to get an algorithm that
can certify that something is a hitting
set so intuitively it's an NP but more
formally what we can do is we can
express this as saying that some system
of equations polynomial equations is
satisfiable that there is a solution so
Ryan talked about this in the morning
and find a field setting here I'm
talking about the algebraic closure
setting basically what you do is you
have some Universal circuit for signs
and the universal circuit is
parameterized by some data arbitrary
complex numbers parameterizing your
circuit and your seq saying is there way
to parameterize the universal circuit
that gives me something that satisfies
this property okay so I'm not actually
go through that but hopefully these
gives you a taste of how you would do
this it's now we're really asking
instead of saying H is not hitting set
if and only if some system of polymer
equations I can write down
has a solution and we just need to then
solve that and the point is is that so
these are in fact I guess enter
locations only integers 0 1 if you want
to be you know okay and so the fact is
is that you can for this problem you can
solve these things in P space
unconditionally using things like
effective mill hill personnel Stalin
size or you can solve it thanks to
Pascal Quran in pH under the generalized
Riemann hypothesis so this is then
saying that we can actually certify that
something is not a hitting set so then
how do we use that to get an algorithm
are all things e very simple we're
basically going to output B first say
this way we're gonna have some set s s
is gonna be a subset of the rational
numbers we're gonna take it some set in
this cube and we're gonna output the
first H which passes the test and what a
part what are the parameters we're
looking at in terms of the size of s and
so on and this is going to be the first
test sets where H and the set s are most
polynomial in s N and D size
the point is is that such H exists which
will pass the test
basically because randon H will exist
will will pass the test
random HR hitting sets and they will
pass this test okay so this is something
and you can clearly do in P space you
just sort of iterate over all such
things these have very small bit length
complexity you just iterate over all of
them you can even do this in pH and just
output the first one that does the test
passes the test and then you get one of
these algorithms okay so this gives us
this result saying that you know for VP
bar or sorry for VP we can construct
heating sites unconditionally in P space
or pH if we add grh so now you have to
ask a question and well look you know VP
for the closure of VP VP bar we have
these exponential space algorithms here
we have P space right and if you define
GCT is the understanding the difference
between these you know we can sort of
quantify our ability to understand the
closure by saying well if you have a
result like this can you extend it to
the closure so really the question is
how do we get hitting sets or a closure
of small directories okay and again the
question is can we guess then certify
this is the algorithm paradigm we used
here can we replicate the success to in
the sidebar setting
now there are two parts of this one is
guests and one is certify and if you had
to guess which one is easier the guests
it is easier okay so random sets work
okay so this is a result of engine
Schnoor
780 s basically saying yeah so if you
take a random set like this it will work
it will be a hitting set for the closure
of small circuits the question then is
how do we certify that something
actually does work and of course you can
use governor basic algorithms but you're
gonna get something in exponential space
and that's not so great okay so the
question then is can we rephrase this
type of question and just you know put a
bar and like hope no one notices what's
the problem the problem is really saying
well here you know we took a small
circuit we converted to the universal
circuit and we observed that the
universal circuit has a small number of
data that we quantify over the question
is well is there a succinct description
of the closure of small circuits that
provides us a way to enumerate overall
small circuits and this is really where
the challenge is all right so what the
problem is let's look at F which is the
limit as epsilon goes to 0 of F sub
Epsilon now for any fixed epsilon this
is succinctly describable
but what about this limiting process the
point is this is potentially complicated
and you can put an exponential bound on
the complexity of this limiting process
but that's actually the best bound that
we have okay so if this is sin
describable you know you have
potentially complicated well complex
times succinct is complex right so this
is this is a complicated so if you
wanted to do this type of thing in the
naive way you would this existential
quantifier would have two exits in to
quantify overall limiting processes
which is too much which is why you get
not pspace exponential space another way
of putting it is if you have epsilon
inside the degree of epsilon can be
exponentially large well random polymers
are not succinct so but I redo I don't
thing we have examples where in in the
small circuit case you can show that the
epsilon has to be exponentially bigger
or not we don't know enough yes
so if epsilon was always smaller than V
P would be equal V P bar but because
it's absolutely big we we don't know and
there may be there are ways around it
you know I don't know at least okay so
okay so the theorem that I now want to
sketch for you in the remaining is a
piece basic algorithm or hitting sets
or sidebar now I just sort of attempted
my best to convince you this was not
gonna work going to work we just have to
do something okay so how do what are we
going to do we're going to change the
notion of a hitting set okay so we're
not going to have just a regular hitting
set we're gonna have something called or
a bus hitting set okay so what is that
okay so in the example that was over
here that I erased where we had F and we
had F sub epsilon and Epsilon on the
zero one point was epsilon squared over
three okay and the problem is is that if
you take the limit of nonzero things
that can be zero unfortunate fact okay
so what we're gonna do to fix this is
just say we don't want our evaluation to
be something that maybe depending on
epsilon we want it to be bounded away
from you okay that's gonna give us the
notion of a per bus hitting set so the
definition of an Epsilon fortunate clash
of collisions is epsilon or bus hitting
set or C is we're going to say that for
all F we're going to have that is non
zero if and only if there exists some
alpha and you're hitting a set where if
you take F and you evaluate on alpha
we're not just asking that it's nonzero
were asking that it's bounded away from
zero and in particular we're gonna ask
that it's at least epsilon times the
norm of F itself okay so we have to
normalize this because if F had really
really really small norm that all the
devaluation is very very small okay so
we're gonna normalize this maybe in the
l2 norm whatever again we're in complex
space so we have l2 norms we're just
asking in the magnitude of this
evaluation captures an epsilon fraction
of the normal graph itself which is why
I said unfortunate cache of collision
okay so why is this helpful okay the key
lemma in this is that suppose that you
have a robust hitting set for size for
small circuits what is this imply
doesn't actually implies that you get
not just hitting test but also robust
hitting sets for the closure
why is that it's a one-word proof its
continuity okay the point is is that
here if you have a limit of polynomials
the norm is continuous so the norm
doesn't really change okay so it's
saying that all your valuations in size
are bounded away from zero so when you
take the limits they must also be
bounded away from zero you no longer
have the limit of nonzero things as zero
you have the limit of things which are
at least a half is at least so I'm no
longer to have epsilon in the notion of
limits I think but so I will change this
so I'm gonna have to put it okay let's
do this okay okay so proof here is
continuity so this is pretty simple
so what this is really saying is that
size bar might be very complicated and
we don't really know how to quantify
over this and a numerator over it so but
instead we can just focus on
constructing robust hitting sets for
size and we kind of numerate oversize
right because these are just small
circuits which we already saw how to do
with talents that's all rhythms okay but
robust hitting sets you know that I
guess that's the key contribution of our
work in some sense in a conceptual sense
because we define them and of course do
they exist and the proposition is that
random sets or robust hitting sets so
this is the key technical contribution
of our work and the sketch of this is
you do the obvious thing and you make a
mirror do all the calculations and it
works so Delta will end up being like 1
over exponential in snd which is
actually sufficient in this case and you
can't actually do much better because
you
look X to the D you know X to the D will
dampen everything an exponential okay so
the sketch of this is basically a
probabilistic method so you'll tell you
you look at random sets and you're gonna
do a turn-off bound and you're gonna do
a Union bound but make this a little bit
more complicated is you also need not
just a concentration bound but an anti
concentration bound because you need to
say that a random polynomial at a random
point assumes a large value
you know pollen goes R and E
concentrated so that they you know
valuations are bounded away from 0
ok and also we're doing a Union bound
over an infinite set and that's kind of
sad right you can't really do that so
what you need is you need again the net
ok to say that we can kind of we don't
actually work with an infinite space we
sort of discretize it appropriately in
the gamma net is actually not too large
in this for algebraic varieties and we
had to kind of this is the key thing to
really do because we had to make up our
own for this ok five more minutes
Emma net is a gamma net of circuits
right so this is a gamma net of size or
size bar actually alright this is an
algebraic variety we're gonna choose a
subset of this algebraic variety so I
said every other point is close to
somewhere in this right so this is some
this and then you can have points saying
you do actually need size bar well it is
just size so you need you need a it's
complicated you need to gamma net in
size but it's a it's a gamma net for
sidebar
you know you just need it for size power
because your Union bounding over I don't
think so but let me let me finish up
okay okay so robust hitting sets exist
and you know if you can find them and
certify them then they automatically
lift from small circuits to the closure
but they're really now the question is
how do you do the certification process
right and dilemma is is that robust
hitting sets can be certified in P space
and so how does this proof go well the
point is is that it's H is not robust
you do the same sort of logical
construction as before each is not
robust if there exists an F in size and
a point alpha naught now we need to
change non zero versus zero a little bit
so F alpha naught it's not just non zero
but it's like large so the norm of this
evaluation is a at least one okay so
this has this is certifying that this
norm is noticeable okay but F on alpha
is very small much smaller than one for
all alpha in our hitting set okay so you
need to quantify exactly how you're
translating and losing norm conversions
and whatever but this is an approximate
quality so we need to do is basic thing
you say I'm giving you an H it sounds
like this and we want to say does it
pass this test can we decide that okay
and it's no longer clear because you
know before we had polynomial systems of
equations and rather equalities and now
we have these inequalities and it's like
sad right but the point is is that this
can be encoded
as simply a polynomial system of
inequalities and no one objected but we
started over the complex numbers and of
course this is all over the real numbers
and no one objected so I'm gonna
continue but this is over argh
ok so a fun fact you know every complex
number is two real numbers so you know
you encode everything appropriately
right and you get that you can take the
system of you know here you have complex
numbers but you encode them as real
numbers and you get a ton of system
equations or inequalities over the real
numbers and then we invoke this very
large hammer but I just which is that
you can do this in key space and this is
by this algorithm of cannae
of 88 which is that this is a fragment
this is a sentence in the in the
existential theory of the reals which is
something you can solve in P space and
that is how you certify it so again the
algorithm is basically we know that
random sets work right so just sort of a
numerator over all possible random sets
until something passes this test when it
passes this test you know that it's
robust hitting set is a robust hitting
set precise and automatically lipsti
sized bar and then you're done okay so
let me just make a few remarks in a lot
and so first remark is that
very nice simplification of Vladimir and
Nitin they basically observed that you
know we use the big hammer here but
there are bigger hammers and you can
actually simplify this a lot by using
not just an existential but basically
kind of putting a for all epsilon here
okay and then you actually don't even
really need to know to show that we're
busting sites that exist there's a small
difference in that sense that here we
actually showing a quantitative lower
bound on the robustness this this
logical approach where you're adding if
Rob's on it won't give you that but it
dramatically simplifies what's going on
here so this simplifies the proof of
course this is still in the
characteristic zero analytic setting
right and so then we'll now talk about
so I wanted to okay you change my
notation but like this is there
something like 4l epsilon I'm not gonna
do this online but basically this is an
epsilon of the of the limiting process
actually no this is no this is the delt
sorry this is all belt this is the Delta
this is like basically you're asking if
is there a hitting set which is Delta
robust for all delta greater strictly
bigger than zero anyway yes we're using
this bigger hammer that if you have a
bound in number of quantifiers and I
just want to highlight the open question
both the algebraic proof that and then
we'll talk about and this proof here
we're really stuck at P space the
intuition should really be that this is
in pH right because you first quantify
overall the hitting sets and then you
ask in the adversarial ask is there a
circuit which violates your possible
hitting set right so there should really
just be like two two rounds of
quantifiers
the reason we're getting pspace is
because we need these these big hammers
we don't know how to we don't we don't
really have good examples so we know
that for degree D polynomials you can
create a degree for it for for certain
like the warning rank I should be the
sample I showed you you can get degree D
separations but we don't have any super
pol metal separations I think even in
you can distinguish let's say in with
two blonde problems right now things you
can do in the limit but you cannot do
yes this is the question also and so so
with the most dramatic thing is that you
looking with two atps and you look at
their closure this is the closure of all
small formulas and this this with two
ATP models not even complete
it's just the greedy of the degree of
deep pollen for Derrida pommels that's
the biggest separation we have d the new
kind of to finally find certain HP elect
norms
[Applause]